arbres déracinés branche qui jonchent le
sol ce résidant de saint roch de
l'achigan n'ai jamais rien vu de tel en
plus de 40 ans je suis but c'est
vraiment comme un entonnoir
en face de la maison et puis après ça
j'ai pu constater tout les tout ce qui
s'était passé ici il ya vingt ans lui
qui est parti j'ai vérifié partout
je n'ai jamais pu la retrouver ces
quatre cas mais rock gentil il a tout
capté hier soir grâce à ses caméras de
surveillance vous voyez la voie royale
qui va bientôt partir d'un rat et voilà
sa conjointe
elle a tout vu de l'intérieur de son
véhicule qu'elle ne pouvait quitter
pendant le passage de la tornade
paralysés par la peur
ma femme chauve camion elles viennent
voir d'un coup je tentais montée
champeymont boucher chaud puis je voyais
plus rien d'une faisait des signes mais
changez pas débarquer loge est trop fort
environnement canada a confirmé que des
vents de 135 à 175 kilomètres à l'heure
accompagnée la tornade de force un viol
dont les flamands établi c'est infernal
gremetz s'est touché la région
lanaudière a conservé de le chien sur
longa d'environ 3 km aura maille
dédommage les ravages les plus
importants ont eu lieu ici sur le
terrain de camping horizon où les
vacances ont pris une autre tournure
quand guillaume chemin des manches en
bois d'affaires germans authier protéger
moi c'était blanc blanc j'ai eu vraiment
un vrai mariage
je suis môme on montrerait pas été ici
j'aurais fadli par ventilation
la bombe est tombée en arrière de la
camionnette la personne est assise d'un
été vraiment chanceux qui arrivent pas
un malin là parce que ça rappelle grève
les tornade de force 1 sont parmi les
plus fréquentes au québec en moyenne de
6,7 tornade par annie sont répertoriés
dans la province
ici mélissa françois radio-canada saint
roch de l'achigan